workshop so I'm happy to have shall give
the first row of the money thanking me
so basically have three goals for this
talk so first I want to tell you what is
this GM MDS conjecture so I'm guessing
that maybe some of you have heard about
something called the MDS conjecture well
not this is not this conjecture two
different conjecture and I'll tell you
what it is so maybe that's not the most
important goal and there is something
about the proof depending how much time
we have and then on the screen at least
the last ten minutes telling you about
some general framework it actually comes
up in a lot of questions about local
codes and and codes for this little
story a lot of types of codes that I
think have a lot of interesting open
problems that people here might like and
and most problems that we have no clue
how to handle and yes I met what is this
GMO yes conjecture so maybe a good end
point
MDS mattresses
so you always gonna have the following
type of matrix K times n matrix K so k
rows and columns it's going to be a fad
Matic says more columns and rows or any
holiday and we say it is MDS if any K
columns
our generally independent
so you have a matrix and you want that
any K by K minor of it to be full rank
or any K columns to be didn't
independence okay so this means this
question comes up you know in coding
theory it comes up in so the randomness
when you want to design K was
independence and we know of no good ways
of designing such matrices so one
example that probably all of you have
seen is the vandermonde matrix right so
I'm on the matrix if you think about it
from a coding perspective so such
matrices if you think of the whole span
has been the basis for code they
generate optimal codes because it has a
optimal trade-off between rate and
distance and so when the mathematics is
just generated matrix for a little more
code this matrices so you walk over some
finite field so you choose some elements
a 1 up to a n some finite field F of
your choice and then just be the
following matrix 1 a 1 a 1 squared 1 a 2
a 2 squared and so on right so I'm
guessing all of you have seen this so it
should not be new and I can ask what
field size do you need to get this to
work and we sort of more or less know
the answer so
strengths on the field sighs well we
need to have in this example we need n
distinct elements right but whenever the
fill has n distinct elements that then
we can get this to work so if you look
on the let's call this maybe minimal on
the minimal field size needed so we know
that the field size is at most n right
we can know if we feel their maximum
okay and actually can pull this is at
least in order to something slightly
better than that so it was stuff more or
less know the answer and actually
figuring out whether it's a know another
two is what's called the MDS conjecture
so then this conjecture is asking about
this type of matrices is in general
fields do you need the field to be set
of size n or can you gets at least
slightly smaller than n or more
generally I'll Reed Solomon codes
optimal or caminos laughing better
so o prime fields it's not the optimal
of a non prime field it's not known but
anyways this is not the topic of this
talk or MDS stands for maximum distance
separable the conjecture here will be
that n that even of a non prime fields
you cannot do better than later on I
mean there's some caveats the field is
characteristics - you might do a little
bit but basically I think the conjecture
is that known examples are optimal so
these are usually the conjectures right
most conjectures about all the examples
we know and say there's nothing more and
ok so this is OK MDS metric says so the
topic of this code this talk is about
MDS matrices with zeros and these
mattresses
strengths so it comes so you asking can
I design a matrix that has a zero in
some coordinates let's just build an
example let's say I'm going to build a
three by five example five points I
wanted to be able to be zero here and
maybe zero here and zero here and
include whatever you want and whatever
you want and whatever you want
here's an example let's call this a zero
pattern so the question
what understand
when can find and
and the s-matrix
specific zero pattern
see the question clear soy the input to
this problem is a matrix there's some
zeros and some stars and your goal is to
replace the stars with whatever you want
okay you want to survive zeros but the
mole is the same and then who somehow
complete the other elements so that
you're going to get an MDS matrix okay
so this is a question why did this
question come up with turns out to
actually be natural when you study
various types of codes that have some
constraints so you want to do this a
some sort of distributed coding and not
everybody could talk to everybody else
and somehow the stuff corresponds to
link that can communicate in the zero so
one that cannot communicate and you
still want to build optimal codes under
some constraints so I don't want to talk
too much about why the description come
out it came up in a number of
applications in a coding and I will just
focus on the mathematics or when can we
do it well the question is clear okay
okay that's a good question
so first let's try to solve it when we
don't care what the field is just say
fitness large enough and that's actually
going to be not too hard there's
actually going to be a very clean
combinatorial characterization when the
field is as large as you want and things
will become more interesting when you
start to restrictive in size
unbounded fields GM is a good question
unclear that I said look at those
original papers and it's not completely
clear what does it stand for
maybe general metrics or something
around with lines maybe I'm wrong and
just code is a GM MD I don't know
anyways I haven't told the conjecture
yet okay so the so far I'm just give me
a big run to the conjecture okay so
about unbounded field size
so okay so there is actually gonna be a
very simple clean combinatorial
characterization when can we do it if
you don't care how other filters use
really huge fields so this condition
that is called in the literature either
MDS condition surprisingly all the
rectangle condition what we meant you
soon see the thing so so 0 pattern P can
be less a completed
and and the s-matrix over huge fields if
and only if the following condition
holds
well no convene at Oriel rectangles
Zelos sighs some a times k plus one
minus a for something holy okay so
little time going to explain I'm going
to show you proof why this is tall it's
not hard but basically said that if you
take a matrix like that you just want to
find all the combinatorics tangles of
zeros everyone here they're not too
large so what is it convenient elect
angle of 0 and just say subst of the
world and the subs' of the columns not
easily contagious that sort of give you
a view so here for example we have this
one I've been here maybe this one this
one this one and you can see in this
example actually they all are okay so
what do we want to verify that if you
look at some of the rows and the columns
should be at most K that's okay it's K
plus 1 you cannot do it
so here it's 2 plus 1 is 3 which is okay
and 2 + 1 + 2 + 1 + 2 + 1 so this should
be okay so why this Commission so this
is this is condition I'm going to take
the next five minutes to tell you why
right so you want to prove two things
why it is necessary and why it is
sufficient
why the MDS mission
so here's so let's say we take an MDS
matrix I'm gonna so here's my MDS matrix
I'm gonna in a given hole how many zeros
gonna have them I cannot have so this is
K this is n if I have K zeros here then
I'm doomed
right because if I take this K by K
matrix it cannot be full and so I cannot
so in any row most K minus 1 zeros so
this is this little bit of will a is 1 1
row K minus 1 that's ok but K is not
okay what about two holes so you have
two O's now it's K minus 1 I claim I'm
still doomed why because if we complete
this to it an arbitrary I did another
column now with the K by K matrix it's
going to be full rank then the span of
the first two holes should be in
dimension to what is dimension one okay
so any two holes
most K minus two common zeros
and so on but every three rows of at
most K minus three it's on okay so this
is necessary otherwise you can easily
find the K by K matrix that is too low
for rec okay so this is a necessary but
what about the sufficient parts
this condition is sufficient what should
you do so let's say we think this is
yellow pattern here so now let's say I
give you huge fields so it's this
efficient large enough things so what
should you do well you should you do the
obvious thing what they will whenever I
see stop I just replace it with a
variable right so I'm gonna say this is
gonna be you can start the following
manic zero zero maybe X 1 X 2 3 0 X 4 0
X 5 X 6 7 X 8 X 9 0 0 and we're gonna
say well let's just write algebraically
the condition that any K by K matrix is
not 0 right so for any K columns
so that's the same I either subset of n
size K P I of X the determinant of this
matrix matrix on the columns I so to
determine of a K by K matrix and
actually this condition is MDS condition
is basically telling you that they're
always going to be at least one monomial
surviving this is basically cool this
whole condition so Dobie one whenever
surviving this disturbance is not
identically zero but if I take the
products of the all possible I of P I of
X this is not going to be identically
zero
so another star Zippin if you take a
large enough field and we should
encourage how large then this will have
a nonzero solution so the question is
how large is the field B so well let's
see so each one of those is a polynomial
of degree K but actually the individual
degree is one which is not important but
you multiply in terms of them n choose K
so the condition is equivalent in any to
this point names are not identically
zero so this is always going to be not
identically zero
because it would be one monomial
surviving and it's an exercise to see
that this commission is equivalent to
this condition
it's basically hole theorem yeah and so
how large was the field be so this is so
buddy
repel or you can just shoot the limits
random if you want but slightly larger
exist the solution if what if the film
more than n choose K right why n choose
K will be multiplying n choose K
polynomials
each of them have degree K so if you
just do it this way that K times n chose
K but as you can say you can share the
fact okay because you really care what
the individual degrees for sure a tipple
the total degree well it doesn't really
matter of the order of n choose K so if
you think i NK will do the same scale in
exponential field size so if you don't
care what the field size then we have a
complete understanding of what's going
on here so again things become
interesting when you start asking about
what if the field is small what if I
don't allow you to walk over huge fields
can we still get this to work well this
approach would not work right also
choosing elements randomly would not
work I think what if I just another way
to put this with slightly larger field
is to say we just choose these elements
randomly and they just say what's the
probability the K by K determinant is
nonzero roughly one of the field size
you have so many of them field is large
enough none of them is going to be 0 so
you don't have to do this algebraically
and also just choose the elements
randomly from a large enough field ok so
now I can tell you what is this GME yes
conjecture the Pope will not work angry
the Pope will not work and somehow also
just choosing elements randomly will not
work with high probability but it might
work with positive probability see we do
care about the solution question I mean
there's no obvious reason why should
improve on it I mean all these events
are the smaller less independent I gave
it's not ability what a local right
every column is a l- careful ya mean
this is - hey that's a good example
let's say there are no zeros so we know
we could do this cut these constructions
but can you do them
probabilistically if you just choose a
random K by n matrix what supposedly MDS
probably very very small right even if
they're not your constraints
finally I can tell about this DMMs
conjecture is
that's conjecture so don't get the names
wrong
right
without and about four years ago so what
these people did is actually saw that
there was a number of papers in coding
theory different areas they tried to
make is made sort of disparate
conjectures about when do the tongue
various codes exist and they basically
said oh we could just put them all under
one umbrella but completing zero
patterns to MDS mattresses somehow
putting several conjectures and the one
one roof so what is this conjecture so
again let's say P so that's maybe a zero
pattern size again K times n satisfies
and this condition can be completed
and the s-matrix over much smaller
fields over fields size
and plus K minus one okay
so this is a very precise conjecture
right somehow so usually it seems you
know okay so we never could it over n
choose K you might try to give some more
Jen say oh v could be small Y talk about
this very precise field of n plus K
minus one
yes know every field of that size or
more there is a way to complete the zero
pattern to to an MVS matrix for anything
yeah yeah so over any anything field of
size either way to do it okay
so why make such bold conjecture but the
reason is actually the head didn't do
black construction can do it if certain
algebraic conjecture would be true so
what I want to tell you about the logic
by construction and about they had the
black conjecture it depends on smaller
then there are exist matrices that they
cannot be done
no basically what they said is that we
want to do it over small fields in an
algebraic way to do it this algebraic
way if it works whether it's field size
but we don't know if it works or not
potentially yes maybe you can move even
smaller that's a good question waiter
the question and then you can do if you
know says end then you can do
[Music]
just say you're trying to prove that
this is no no no I'm saying the
conjecture is not about tightness what
about the existence so the existence
well you could ask so we know you need n
maybe or another two you can ask do you
need something between n to n plus K
what's the right answer I don't know
maybe you can do some some better
examples but this is of the order of n
is at most two N and this is exponential
in n so somehow we have carry but the
constants is good but so the first go
for explanation to dinner now these are
all good questions I agree and someone
tell you about the algebraic
construction
okay but the congestion is clear you can
under the same condition if you get
maybe a different solution or no much
much smaller filters construction so the
first thing is you say well let's say we
didn't have any zero conditions how can
we realize and yes metrics as well we
know random on the matrices so one
component would be with my metrics is
gonna have one part here K times n of
endomondo metrics for 1 a 1 a 1 squared
1 a 2
no this is an MDS matrix but it has no
zeros so there's a question what
operations can I do on this matrix and
keep it MDS but might introduce some
zeros and that's a good some change of
basis right I can also multiply let's
call this matrix TV it also multiplied
here on the left by a matrix T so this
is a K by K matrix this just gonna be
full wreck
it's gonna stay
so the conjecture is that well you can
do that that's gonna work why it's not
clear yet well we're going to start
simplifying the conjecture that it'll
become clear okay at this point it
should not become clear and also this
point this might look like which
perfectly like you know somehow tell oh
the list we have chosen field elements
and whether we have chosen change of
basis such as you can zero is exactly
where you wanted to get okay
why okay so when we're gonna start to
simplify this conjecture we're gonna
little bit actually there's this rabble
that's what the conjecture is clear so
we're gonna try to pull so the goal
would be any zero pattern that satisfies
yes condition
can be completed
this way there's a choice of the matrix
T yeah so some have to be careful in how
you choose a wanna play again and
careful how you choose T and then you
hold your fingers and you hop into the
work there's a non-random solution
do not walk you also write Binaca so now
let's start to simplify it
and
so the goal will be to simplify it in a
way that in some sense we will have a
unique choice of T and a unique choice
of elements in some way so that we don't
have any degrees of freedom anymore so
that we the goal of the simplification
of this conjecture I'm gonna replace
this matrix T by some other elements the
polynomials okay find polynomials
f1f kx4 the univariate polynomials or
the feel of degree most k minus 1 f i X
and I'm just going to basically treat
the rows of this matrix T as the
coefficients of the polynomial so f IX
is just going to be the sum of j-1
okay well the matrix T I J X to the J
minus 1 okay and now what does it mean
that this matrix a realizes so completes
envelope a turn
whenever I see a 0 in P I should see a 0
here right so what do we want we want so
so what we do we want we want that if P
IJ 0 this would imply that hey
IJ 0 but what is AI J AJ is just you
take the I throw here and you multiply
with a J's column here so this is the
same as if I over AJ
so because automatics visa vandermonde
matrix the IJ entry value in the ice
polynomial on the Jade field element
okay so now you can say well we just
rewrote a condition what do you want
remote this K polynomials
so we want a linearly independent
in Amiens f1 up to FK x was K minus 1
such that if I AJ 0 whenever it should
be 0 whenever P IJ so you just worry
about the condition so now what we will
say somehow choose some field elements
and now trying to me some polynomials
are linearly independent while I mean
independent that's equivalent for to
being fully independent and it should be
0 in the specific locations so
simplification let's do step 2 we'll say
let's try it now to identify these
polynomials so let's assume for now just
for a second that every row in P has as
many zeros as it could have actually try
to be easier just introduce notation
that so let's define s I just to be all
the locations J or P IJ is 0 so si is
all the coordinates in the I throw the
way I want it to be 0 and the seal si of
size exactly K minus 1 which is a
maximal site could have right I could
not have K zeros in a row but he could
have K minus 1 zeros you know I live in
this case there's only one choice for fi
fi is a polynomial K minus 1 that should
be 0 this K minus 1 points so in this
case
you must have
FIF X in exactly the product of J in Si
X minus AJ okay so something like you
can assume that all the rows have the
maximal number of zeros then we go to
the one degree of freedom we don't have
to think with this plain number so
that's was uniquely given to us if we
choose the field elements so now you can
ask can you make this assumption and the
answer is yes so if your matrix has some
holes with less than K minus 1 zeros you
can add zeros to it such as it still
satisfies the MDS condition and such
that it's going to have exactly K minus
1 zi was inevitable how can we do it so
here's an easy way but it'll be a better
way so the easy way is to say if this is
a K by N and let's say here I only have
hey - - I just wanted another 0 here I'm
gonna put stars here this is this would
not violate the MDS condition and we
know exactly K minus 1 well this has a
downside of slightly increasing n is
gonna be inevitable so you can keep
doing that and then n is going to be a
slightly bigger okay that's one we thing
to do okay no there's actually a better
way to do it which does not require to
introduce more columns but so you use of
uses some hole type condition to show
that you can always add zeros and still
satisfy the whole condition you could do
whatever you want right I could say I
want to play now it's too busy
if you take the point numbers is going
to be 0 somewhere else I don't care even
right so - well this would make is it
make your filter does n be slightly
bigger than n plus K it's gonna be maybe
n plus 2 K 1 plus K square or something
so you gonna pay something if you do
that
it's a big emetics but did you satisfy
this then in particular on this path
you're going to be zeros where you want
to be zero right so your dad to the
stronger but you're gonna pay if you do
that because the field we study bigger
at the end but I think you don't have to
do that so either way just it zeros to
the matrix we see this is like you can
multiply each we have exactly like case
where - cape conditions right into the
noise scale then you just try to match
like the dimensions of your constraints
and dimensions of your degrees of this
is not this is not eligible Commission
dismiss MDS condition but the zeroes of
the rectangles of zero singer metrics so
I mean I don't know how you okay so this
is the white case come on it's game
every roll you say I want these entries
okay the holding the column yes yes also
I don't know if you can use this
argument to prove that they didn't
exactly get this conditionals about the
condition with the same little freedom
but anyway that means it's a nice
exercise it's like a whole pep condition
so so like in the original paper they
prove that you can always do that you
can reduce to this case yes
so why is it important it's one of them
of sins we just forget about it because
that's a good question because I want to
get paid knows that the get K minus one
and if they have less and they then have
some degrees of freedom tonight I could
choose February of polynomials that are
veil on these powerpoints but I don't
know what what they are so you might say
well but what is this polynomial if my
polynomial has K minus 1 roots in the
get K minus one - just one choice you
could do that but then this will be
false is a good question but I'm sure
why this is action doesn't doesn't walk
ya repeat the question
the other fish yes so what the meal was
asking is why can't you just say what if
you have K minus 2 or less then we just
define the pnom Aeolus to be the product
of the zeros and sort of ignore the rest
so someone shooting the minimal degree
polynomials so here's an example where
this would fail so here's a matrix let's
say I just have no let's say I have no
zeros I just have stars so I get K
paramus of degree zero they're gonna be
in an independent
you will show that all of them
independently tremendous what are the
numbers and if you have less than K
minus one zeros you have a degree you
have a space of polynomials so be sure
that there is a one polynomial you can
choose on the space for every row but
this this is a specific program and only
if you have exactly K minus one let you
have K minus two so they want to again
it is a polynomial but I'm saying if you
have a lesson came and some other other
polynomials so this would fake so this
specific choice would fail because let's
assume that you have no zeros in your
matrix then this program is gonna be a
constant as we want
let's say let's say this is all stars I
think this is all should be completed
today I putted a zero and a zero and a
zero okay let's just be complete let's
say this is my metrics
so what other programmers are suggesting
we're going to be X minus a 1 X minus a
2 and X minus a 3 right so there are
going to be been an independent so this
would not work but you could use other
point numbers like it should here a
quadratic polynomial X is 0 on a 1 & 0
somewhere else and in a different code
the logical method quadratic admitted to
be linearly independent so there is a
way to do it but not using these
polynomials we need some quadratic point
numbers for that and the goal here is
just to say I want to limit my choice
say let's walk in the case where there's
no choices to be made so if you're doing
this is natural but doesn't work now the
flip side didn't come up yet okay so we
did one thing so we're going to assume
for now this assumption that we had
exactly K minus 1 0 is inevitable so at
least we fixed so if you fix the field
elements that least fix the polynomials
the next step is going to be somehow
remove the choice of the field elements
so how can you do it well you cheat you
say I'm going to extend my feet so I'm
going to walk
the same let anyone after a and now not
be field elements by these of you know
new variables let's walk in the field F
of a one after that
so again so now that just you know place
all those some extent oo variables right
now everything is completely determined
so now let's write that now you can
write an algebraic conjecture
the fallen conjecture so again P is a
zero pattern
satisfies
yes condition woman yo si was a set of
holiness jailer pIJ 0 we assume the set
of sy is exactly K minus 1 all I another
just one chance of polynomial so we
define Phi of X to be the product during
si X minus AJ okay now these are not
three elements no there are new
variables so the conjecture is this the
set of polynomials then you want up to
if you can you see it here should remove
that oh you guys cannot see okay they
should tell me you can see but they
cannot see the skin there any other one
move there and uh but okay so these
polynomials change
we defined the point known as Nelson is
uniquely defined by the Vela pattern
then what then the set of polynomials P
1 up to PK be not only dependent over
the field extended to any field for any
field this is fine this is why anything
for anything this is Adam
so so far there are no expressions of
the fields we have to the restrictions
on the field would come up when you say
let's say this is - how do I realize it
by actually replacing this a I'd field
elements then you're gonna start having
restrictions on the field size he went
up to the end so for every field element
to choose I chose a favorable so this is
the algebraic conjecture that they
stated that this if this is true then
this construction walks independent so
not even now we're going to see why this
restriction the field size come up so
assume this is true
so this is 2 so we need to be place AI
with field elements
right and now they're going to be some
conditions so what what the conditions
do we have so what do we need so one you
want all of them to be different we
don't know that we have in the same
fiend element otherwise the vandermonde
apart would not work
secondly the one this matrix T to be
full round
I thought T was the message that somehow
defined by these polynomials so these
two conditions and both of them you can
actually express by polynomials on the
AI right so this first condition which
is not expressed by saying the product
of the polynomials AI minus AJ zero this
is going to be the determinant of T
which is some polynomial in the AIS and
basically what this conjecture tells us
this determinant is not identically 0
this is an equivalent way to state this
algebra conjecture that whenever the 0
pattern satisfy the MDS condition this
determinant is not identically 0 so if
you take these as the roots of the
polynomial and you explain it to the
coefficients then you take this
determinant this is this is a ok so now
just gonna be a counting degrees to see
what field size do we need so to do
shave out zip L what do we need to count
well it's not the total degree of the
polynomial
but it's the maximal individual degree
of a variable appear in the Pannonian
so here every verbal appears K minus 1
times so n minus 1 time so this is gonna
give us n minus 1 and here in verbal
appeals K minus 1 times the calculation
so if you something to the individual
different variable is n plus K minus 2
yeah you take the point is the first
point number let's say it has specific
holds you expand it to the coefficients
and this will be the first law so every
elements there is some polynomial in
their eyes it's a symmetric polynomial
in the AIS
what is one except for the first two
were the old one this is where I get to
K minus one yeah and it's n minus 1
whatever because at minus 1 product
choice
so yes conjecture we basically the
conjecture basic theories in this
determinant is not identically 0 of
course it said that ecclesia are nothing
you can do but it's not identically zero
and and this is to over any field but
now when try to we to solve these two
point numbers together you get the
polynomial where the individual degrees
are n plus k minus 2 so you need one
more you needa feel to be impressed k
minus 1 so this is where you get this n
plus K minus 1 so basically what I
pulled is this algebraic on JSTOR but I
don't think I have time to prove it the
remaining 10 minutes and I was hoping to
have more time to explain the pause but
at least you got that the Y conjecture
and field doesn't matter
and can you say something about so you
yes ii say something about the proof so
turn that if you try to prove it
directly it doesn't work so the natural
way to do someone to do induction on the
structure of the zeros and this turns up
to be too weak of an inductive
assumption so you need to walk in a more
general assumption
so the moralistic agreement about the
proof
so really what you should be doing
obviously what I do is to allow multiple
zeros so if you think you can view this
zero star pattern as saying some points
it should be zero in some part you
shouldn't be zero but the more general
thing you can think of as the following
type of matrix let's say if initially
ahead zero and starts now we won't have
zero one two one and that's going to be
the number of zeros if this is let's say
a 1 a 2 a 3 a 4 this would correspond to
the polynomial X minus a 2 X minus a 3
squared X minus a 4 so I'm having a lot
of multiple roots at specific points so
you can ask a more general question
which is we can even define an MDS
condition for these types of matrices
and there's a natural way to do it then
you can ask the question well if this
general MDS condition you satisfied
maybe they put this point normally to
get this more general one with multiple
roots are also going to be linearly
independent the sum of the second it's a
it's a natural you must want to be like
the sum of this means okay so I don't
want to state with this condition is
that of the natural condition about
counting zeroes so actually in the
original paper actually made a
conjecture to what they pulled is
missing a special case I'll tell you in
a second but actually I made a
conjecture that said well if this
general condition is true then you can
always this polynomials are always gonna
be lean on independent this is actually
false so I think of an example well
honestly I don't ever this is an example
this is by
so so here's an example the children
this in general these things are not to
ourselves more interesting phenomenon we
don't quite understand this is by and
yadi so he was sober today so it's clear
how this metric somehow defines binomial
so here's their example weight zero zero
zero three zero zero zero three one one
one okay so basically this corresponds
to the fine print no miles so remember X
minus a 1 cubed x minus a 2 cube X minus
a 3 cubed and X minus a 1 X minus a 2 X
minus a 3 is 4 put this this is weird
because K is bigger
yes but sort of you can do that this
point doesn't really matter if K 2 more
than n we could add more zeros it if you
want change yeah if you wanted you said
modules so you know I got this for
polynomials of degree 3 well there is no
obvious way where there will be linearly
independent but they are in an
independent so these are linearly
dependent
or anything that you choose extended a
1-800 so if you're allowed to check
thick for efficient which are rational
functions of animals my three they're
going to me you know the dependence when
you can verify it but I have zero
intuition why this is 2 so one general
open question here is that what are the
condition that this would be true
so there are this obvious or this
natural condition which are not enough
and I have no clue what are the right
conditions so what I actually pulled is
that if you there are limited classes of
these matrices without enough to get the
induction going but I can actually pull
these things actually work and this is
where you only have two zeros and ones
so only single Goods except for the last
column so here you allowed to have some
large number so only the last column
your lot I want approach somehow I say
maybe surprisingly it is a strong enough
condition that sort of allows you to do
induction and it so we can have
conditioner to beat or induction about
the structure of the zeros so again I
can explain it but you take another half
hour so I don't take the time but
basically what you do we say let's take
somehow zero pattern and you want to say
where it has so many low so many columns
and so on and try to say well let's say
this is the smallest example with this
conjecture fails and try to show this is
impossible by somehow using sub
structures in it can give me more
details but the proof is elementary
there's no deeper geometry it just sort
of combinatorics and algebra and also
import this was also so this the same
conjecture was also poured independently
by in this form Kartik so support the
same conjecture the same time more or
less I mean virgin elevation was that we
differed but the also did some
generalization
so I think I have another five minutes
or maybe slightly more to tell you but
unless our questions about this but a
more general framework for these type of
problems for basically we understand
nothing
generally walk
so the general Islamic we still don't
have a zero star patterns of a pattern P
star but we make no assumption about it
now there's no longer an MDS conditional
vector addition no assumption right so
we have no assumption your assumption
so what's going to be the goal will be
to complete P to a metric do this as
general as possible given that you know
some things will not there's no way you
can achieve so complete the metrics
okay so the place to start and field
elements such that any minor okay that
can be full rank
we'll be okay so for example
I think my matrix pattern is zero stuff
zero stop okay so I mean it doesn't
matter what I do the first color is
going to be zero but I want these to
toss this within an independent so
there's a question clearly make some
zero stars no assumption whatsoever and
again the question is what's the field
size we need so what is the minimal
field size what the answer would depend
on whatsoever
this is the same as this MDS condition
right without zeros this is one demand I
would do it for example and what I prove
that if you have so few zeros that all
the maximal miners are full rank then
you can do it but in general condition
and I what I want to do is show that
these questions actually come up very
naturally in questions about sort of you
know various types of local sparse codes
in various ways so I want you to
examples what these regions come up you
can ask for all the holes or sort of the
rows will both make sense I think it was
most variants make sense here
so yeah that is towards okay
so if you have zeros and someone donat
going to be zero alright so somehow you
cannot get all the way to this extreme
but you can say about two by two means
you need something some kind of coma
zero body which can be ranked should be
full right right so but this is not just
a method for all the miners are gonna be
full rank all the manuals that can be if
the first five columns could be another
independent they should be if every
specific 3x3 matrix could be for what it
should be so this is stronger than this
in this condition in particular let's
say that whenever you see a starship put
a non zero value there because otherwise
you organ evaluate some one-by-one
commissions so I want to just tell you
about two two examples example one comes
from a codes for distributed storage
so basically so imagine you have the
assists story let's not let's hear the
data center and you want to do error
correction it's somehow your note that
you have service and each server can do
local self correction and this is good
for maybe some sporadic failures but you
also do some global self correction over
the entire data center so that if you're
a few servers die you can still turn or
something so how can we couldn't
describe using this type of framework so
here's the matrices that you get so it
has two parts the bottom part is for the
local thing so you have some blocks here
star zero and then here you have a
number stars
so yes the best part is you know how big
is this uh big is that how many groups
you have many elements a few service
parameters you can do anything ask can
you build these codes so people actually
actually work on distributed storage and
con codes they're actually build these
types of codes and usually that the
filter that they need grow stuff you
know if this is very small everything's
very small everything is nice
once you start having more redundancy
constraints you start to pay for it and
the question is is this in fact
necessary so do you need to pay up when
you want one more constraints and so
that their I don't know if only one walk
that pose lower bounds here and this is
by a this is going to be copy and I
guess Venkata Goswami sorry
so they have a walk the show that in
some of the gyms here they can prove
some low bonds the field size and the
poop is very tailored to this type of
setting so it's not some generic proof
technique it's a very Taylor to this
walking sanguine gyms and also I had a
walk with some kids run Daniel K that
walked on a similar metrics were you
allowed to do this doji so in the strap
right well you also have you have some
if you go through your data center where
you have local redundancy on servers
like that and also like that so you can
also realize this as a matrix they will
track it and then we can post of optimal
bonds on the film size but the proofs
are very as the ad hoc they're very
tailored to the specific type of zero
stock pattern that come from the co
topology so we don't have any general
proof techniques the Poussin varies very
tailored here's an in a second example
where we sort of do not approve into
single bonds but there it was in October
depends on the regime of the parameter
so that like five different parameters
and it depends I mean something where it
is some optimal in some and very
suboptimal in others I mean I can tell
you offline there's no clean answer here
but there is a technique to post a blob
and at least that in San Joaquin is
going to be exponential and the second
example - you know these are codes for
this interactive communication and they
actually get a very simple matrix the
diagonal starts below the diagonal zero
above the bed so you can ask you for
this type of matrix yes
what type of K by K minors could
potentially be non singular and turns
out these are exactly the ones you need
to analyze for three codes and then you
ask what's the field size you need to
get this to work and actually so there
was this very very nice recent work so
it was a and the main I would say from
being a toil part of their walk is to
use the constructor for such matrices of
a very large field so what they put if
you choose mathematics AI J to be I
guess I choose J this works
the constants like clean but you see it
requires exponential numbers is this
necessary unclear so we don't know if
over finite fields all over the integers
you need exponential numbers or not
actually this could be in this an
example will it might be that of a
finite fields you need exponential
numbers but over the integers you don't
so it's actually really discuss over the
integers might be better than because of
finite fields here and but this is just
another example you can think of a
general set of problems and basically we
have no general proof no bonds or
techniques here that only two that we
have a very very Taylor to the very very
specific apology so just to finish let
me tell you but conjecture I have that
has no applications but I think
it's nice I thought it's enforceable
find some genetic roof technique
check show
so let's be random pattern random I mean
that the probability that P IJ is 0 the
point is that they have so you choose
random 0 star pattern with probability
1/2 have a random here and you want to
realize this by a matrix that has by the
miner that you happen to be potential
full right here should be full rank so
here's the conjecture so to realize this
exponential field says financial in size
so somehow completely if this pattern so
they say if P okay times N and let's say
K is I don't know and over 2 or
something parameter so so that'll be
balanced matrix n over two by n it
should be friend only three like this
I mean basically the whole point here is
to say if it's random there's no reason
why it should get energy black
construction like a name like a reed
solomon that realizes this and one such
a black construction stop talking it
seems that you need exponential field
size but we have not to involve anything
like that so that's one complete
conjecture Thanks
[Applause]
so except this behavior by Thailand stop
something it read about a year old
it wasn't put in the world in this field
in stock I believe right well then stop
is here yeah I know
and so they know actually even discuss
your paper so they start with this as a
starting point and then use some
recursive construction to reduce the
field size to be almost optimal yeah I
see what catechize mentioned until whoa
and I'll say that this is one
construction but they are certainly they
don't prove the use this I to you and
tell other papers that sort of pull this
in other independent context but Henry
use this as a starting point if you
could get this thing to work with the
numbers here of polynomial itself
exponential size and then you get
optimal records essentially no so here
this is obsessed to to then if you get
boolean but I mean the canal can ask
this question megabits false problems
here but you cannot do it in this way
if it said thanks chef
[Applause]